storm malik has battered much of
northern england and scotland damaging
power lines and cutting off tens of
thousands of homes in aprily bridge in
west yorkshire a driver was fortunate to
walk away from this
firefighters in greater manchester
rescued a woman from her car after a
tree had crashed through its roof
but in aberdeen a 60 year old woman was
killed by a falling tree
nearly 50 000 homes are without power in
scotland across aberdeenshire angus
perthshire and murray engineers have
been drafted in from wales and cheshire
to help
winds of more than 100 miles per hour
have been recorded in parts of scotland
with several a-roads shut in
aberdeenshire and major disruption to
the rail timetable
in northumberland and county durham 36
000 homes are still without power i've
lived in the islands here for
over 21 years and you just kind of get
used to this kind of thing so i'm always
prepared i've always got a good stalker
but we've got a
camping stove so it's got two rings and
a grill so we can have hot drinks we can
have toast we can warm food up so
you just you just learn to be prepared
and
resourceful and check the neighbors are
okay and that sort of thing
in a statement northern power grid said
storm malik is causing disruption to our
network as it continues to move across
our operating area
our teams are responding restoring power
through alternative routes on our
network where possible assessing damage
and coordinating repairs wherever
conditions permit
the bad news for many is that there is
little prospect of immediate respite
storm curry will roll in on sunday with
a yellow weather warning in place for
scotland and northern england
ender brady sky news